hey what is up guys mkbhd here and back
at ces 2014 this january not only did i
catch a tesla model s at the panasonic
booth but i also found
this so this is a 4k
tough pad tablet from panasonic and you
know it's absolutely ridiculous for a
normal person i mean this is a 20 plus
inch tablet it's heavy it's got a ton of
graphics power behind it it's very
expensive but of course the display was
absolutely ridiculously good looking it
had an amazing pixel density and a ton
of sharpness and detail as you would
expect from something that's 4k and so
that got me thinking
where is all the 4k so this is the state
of 4k as of february 2014. uh so below
this video if youtube processed it right
you will see the 240p option the 480p
option the 720p option the 1080p option
the 1440p option and if all went well a
2160p option and that is for the
3840x2160 version of this video what
we'll call 4k so right off the bat 4k
video is four times the resolution of
1080p video or if you look at it on the
same size screen it's four times as
pixel denser four times as detailed that
is amazing that's going to look great on
pretty much any size so the question is
why isn't everything already 4k
and uh the short answer is
it's difficult it's difficult to shoot
4k it's difficult to process 4k output
4k and display and playback 4k so when
we say it's difficult to shoot 4k video
that literally means that the cameras
that we're using that will all shoot
1080p just fine don't quite have the
processing power or the sensors capable
of shooting 4k video such a high
resolution video a perfect example of
that is the gopro hero 3 plus black
edition that'll shoot 4k video but only
at 15 frames per second it can't quite
muster the processing power to go beyond
that and then something like the samsung
galaxy note 3 it is a pretty powerful
phone but it'll only shoot at a
relatively low bit rate long story short
uh if you're going to get high quality
high frame rate high bitrate high
resolution video you're going to need a
very expensive very powerful camera and
those are coming down in price now but i
did a video on all the 4k camera options
i saw at ces last month so i'll leave
that linked right below the like button
but if you get anything out of watching
that video is that it can be quite
expensive to shoot a high quality 4k
video alright so this is a 4k tv
legitimately it's a 3840 by 2160 panel
i'll have the link and the model number
right below that like button uh and so
this
is is fully able to display 4k content
at any time
but it has never actually displayed 4k
anything ever so what's hooked up to
this as you can probably tell by the nba
right now is the playstation 4
and xbox one and an apple tv and none of
which will actually output 4k through
hdmi and there's also a chromecast
plugged into this tv that won't do 4k
either so as far as we're concerned this
is all still 1080p stuff and as much as
i love to you know play nba or forza
in 4k with the insane detail of that
high resolution or watch netflix in 4k
or chromecast tv shows in 4k nothing
will do that right now and that's
actually the case for a lot of people so
really no reason to go buy a 4k tv
because as far as we're concerned this
is still acting exactly like a 1080p tv
alright so this is a 4k desktop display
it's one of the few monitors you can put
on your desk that will have that 3840 by
2160 resolution this is the asus pq321q
and right now it's hooked up to a mac
pro via thunderbolt which is one of the
few ports that will actually output 4k
uh at an acceptable frame rate 60 hertz
is really what i mean by that uh but
here's the thing about that uh go ahead
and full screen this video
hit it full screen you got this you got
it you got it full screen for a sec all
right check this out
boom this is what the desktop looks like
in 4k and it looks all super tiny
because in mac os 10 there's very
limited high dpi scaling support so
unfortunately everything looks super
duper small coming from a higher
resolution monitor but this is what your
display would look like if it was 4k
without any sort of scaling really small
i know so i'm hoping when apple finally
releases their own 4k display they'll
update mac os 10 with more high dpi
options so that things don't have to
look quite this tiny but then again my
eyes have already kind of gotten used to
it anyway but at the end of the day when
it comes down to it when you get a setup
that can show 4k video on a 4k display
without taking up all your bandwidth and
without dropping frames it's an amazing
experience it looks beautiful it's
incredibly detailed but the problem is
the number of people with setups that
check all those boxes is very very small
in fact most laptops if you guys are
watching this on a laptop most laptops
won't really play back 4k video 100
without dropping any frames
and most of them don't even have 4k
displays anyway and neither do our
phones and neither do most of our
tablets except for i guess that brings
us back to that ridiculous panasonic 4k
tablet from the beginning uh most people
are totally fine with 1080p and they'll
say that like that's great 1080p looks
fine but once you see 4k video or super
high resolution video played back
natively without any of those problems
that is typically associated with it is
amazing and then you can't really go
back i call it the retina display effect
once you see such high resolution stuff
everything else starts to look fuzzy so
as much as we love 4k and all its
sharpness and all its pixels here in the
tech community it is still a long way
from being widely adopted but it's
definitely starting in fact this is the
year that i think we're going to see the
biggest shift from people seeing 1080p
as a standard to people seeing 4k as a
standard and you're going to see a lot
more 4k tvs in stores and a lot more of
that 4k talk in those ads in the future
so right now if i had to put the state
of 4k in a single word it would be
momentum
it started off a little while ago that
word was potential but now it has a lot
of momentum moving forward if you went
to ces basically everyone there was
showing some sort of 4k tv and that made
me really happy because i love pixels
and eventually we're gonna see a whole
lot more 4k stuff all around so that's
been it hopefully you enjoyed this video
and if you did feel free to share it
that's about it i guess i've said that's
it several times already now thank you
for watching and i'll talk to you guys
in the next video peace
you